[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 14 juin voici le programme
de ce soir des chaises des tables ou
encore des ordinateurs l'association
container sans frontières basées à
Élancourt a rempli un container entier
de fournitures et de Mobilis scolaires
pour un lycée au Sénégal on en parle
avec les deux fondateurs de
l'association implantez depuis octobre
2022 dans les anciens locaux du collège
Paul Cézanne à Mantes-la-Jolie le
nouveau campus de formation du
département des Yvelines a organisé une
journée portes ouvertes le week-end
dernier coiffure métier du bâtiment ou
encore service à la personne le bâtiment
propose une vingtaine de formations nous
dressons un premier bilan et enfin c'est
inédit les communes de Châteaufort et de
Toussus-le-Noble se sont affrontés ce
week-end lors d'Olympiades tir à la
corde course de brouette ou encore
ventrigliss les habitants et les mers
ont tout donné l'objectif re le code
postal similaire aux deux villages mais
dans cette émission nous parlerons
également de la Garden Party organisée
par le département des Yvelines ce sera
samedi prochain Julien bloûtant bonsoir
alors vous êtes le sous-directeur
adjoint au pôle gestion et valorisation
du patrimoine pour les départements des
Yvelines première question
en quelques mois à quoi faut-il
s'attendre pour cette garden party
samedi prochain quel est le programme du
soleil une entrée gratuite et des
animations gratuites
11 concerts que des artistes locaux sauf
un qui nous vient de Belgique donc je
l'ai dit des activités gratuites en
termes de décoration végétale du sport
de la zumba et du sourire un programme
chargé donc on en parlera plus en détail
dans quelques instants avec nous
également sur le plateau je le disais à
l'instant les deux fondateurs de
l'association container sans frontières
Christophe Jean Mougin bonsoir bonsoir
et El Hadji Dramé bonsoir bonsoir alors
pareil en quelques mots est-ce que vous
pouvez nous présenter votre association
l'association container sans frontières
cette association c'est une association
de solidarité internationale
Kenny avant d'être association c'était
un projet scolaire et ça s'est
transformé en association en octobre en
décembre 2021 on a créé l'association
avec elaji pour faire perdurer le projet
en fait donc là vous avez envoyé un
premier container au Sénégal en fait
c'est notre deuxième le premier c'était
un collège qui l'a envoyé elle devienne
c'était vraiment l'association voilà
donc on en parlera dans quelques
instants également plus en détail on
parlera également de votre journée
solidarité que vous organisez dimanche
prochain avec nous également une
journaliste de la rédaction c'est une
Charles bonsoir bonsoir avec vous vous
allez nous présenter les informations à
retenir dans les Yvelines ce sera juste
après les prévisions météo de demain
demain matin nous nous réveillerons
toujours avec un beau soleil sur tout le
département des Yvelines au niveau des
températures comptées 20 degrés à
Rambouillet et Houdan et 21 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles dans
l'après-midi le beau temps sera toujours
au rendez-vous côté température il fera
toujours aussi chaud compter en moyenne
28 à 29 degrés et demain nous fêterons
légère Maine le point maintenant sur
l'actualité dans les Yvelines
et on commence Céline par notre image du
jour direction Les Mureaux ou plusieurs
enfants du territoire se sont lancés
dans un tournoi de rugby géant oui
mathilde a quelques mois de la Coupe du
monde de rugby 2023 la ville des Mureaux
organisée drop en scène une mini-coupe
du monde de rugby sur le territoire
yvelinois alors 20 équipes d'enfants de
9 à 11 ans se sont rendus au stade Léo
Lagrange des Mureaux pour s'affronter en
match de poule puis match éliminatoire
les équipes étaient composées d'enfant
le 9 villes différentes Aubergenville
Les Mureaux Magnanville Epone boivent le
Chapet Flins-sur-Seine Gargenville et
Verneuil-sur-Seine chaque équipe
représentait une nation qualifiée pour
la Coupe du monde alors l'événement
permet aux enfants Yves Linois de vivre
la passion du rugby avant la coupe mais
surtout au-delà de la compétition de les
initiés au sport et aux valeurs qui sont
associés on vous en dira un petit peu
plus prochainement lors d'un reportage
sur TV 78 on continue avec cette
information Céline à villaines-sur-seine
chaque patrouille de la police
municipale est maintenant équipée de
caméra piétons humain Mathilde se sont
de petites caméras placées de façon
apparente sur le devant du harnais
t-shirt ou gilet par balle des policiers
le fonctionnaire pourra décider
d'enclencher la caméra en fonction de
l'intervention les individus filmés en
sont prévenus en amont une fois
enclenché elles enregistre l'image et le
son ces caméras piétons devraient
permettre une meilleure communication et
sécurité des agents et je cite le
communiqué de presse de la ville cela
dissuade les comportements agressifs et
réduit le risque de violence à l'égard
des agents elle fournissent également
des preuves visuelles essentielles pour
les enquêtes et les poursuites
judiciaires le bureau de poste de
Saint-Cyr-l'École sera fermée pendant un
peu plus de deux mois Céline mais
Mathilde est la raison c'est qu'il fait
bonheur des travaux de rénovation
débuteront le lundi 26 Juin prochain
date à laquelle le bureau fermera ses
portes pour plusieurs semaines pour
l'ensemble des opérations postales et
bancaires la ville vous invite en
attendant à vous rendre au bureau de
poste de Fontenay-le-Fleury vous pouvez
également vous rendre sur les services
disponibles en ligne comme la poste.fr
ou la banque postale.fr pour ce qui est
de la distribution du courrier rien
n'est impacté elle se fera comme
d'habitude la réouverture du bureau est
prévue pour le 5 septembre prochain et
cet après-midi se déroulait la finale
d'un autre concours d'éloquence celui du
château de Versailles intitulé lycéen
trouve ta voix il avait lieu dans la
somptueuse salle du Congrès et si
lycéens de seconde dont deux de
l'académie de Versailles ont pris la
parole pour la finale inter-académique
de ce concours alors ils avaient été
lauréats des différentes du concours
parmi près de 2000 élèves de lycées
publics prioritaires les élèves ont
suivi une formation à la prise de parole
de 10 semaines dispensées par 70
étudiants bénévoles dans 30 lycées des
académies de Paris Créteil et Versailles
une formation qui leur a permis de
prendre confiance en eux de se préparer
au grand oral du bac la question posée
lors de la finale de cet après-midi
c'était que voudriez vous dire au monde
alors les élèves ont tour à tour défilé
devant un jury notamment composé de
Charline Avenel rectrice de l'académie
de Versailles et c'est Liana une élève
du Lycée Emmanuel Mounier de
Châtenay-Malabry qui a remporté le
concours et on en profite d'ailleurs
pour faire un petit clin d'oeil aux
nombreux élèves ivinois qui passaient le
bac de philosophie ce matin alors
c'était l'avant-dernière épreuve avant
le grand oral à partir de la semaine
prochaine alors attention il va falloir
vous replonger un petit peu dans vos
cahiers accrochez-vous parmi les thèmes
ont retrouvé le bonheur est-il à faire
de raison ou encore vouloir la paix
est-ce vouloir la justice alors je sais
pas si ça vous inspire autour du plateau
ce thème ce thème en fait finalement
j'ai toujours aimé la philosophie
j'ai pas encore réfléchi au sujet mais
ça m'intéresserait
plutôt j'ai une bonne note et la vie de
ramener oui moi j'ai pas fait la
philosophie avec ce qui est la partie
technologique et l'informatique et vous
Julien on a combien de temps
et vous Mathilde moi j'avais une
question sur le bonheur et je trouve que
les questions sont très bien cette année
enfin c'est toujours un petit peu
compliqué quand même pour répondre mais
c'est toujours un peu en rapport avec
l'actualité c'est bien on est d'accord
ah oui oui on pourra en parler pendant
des heures il y a de quoi répondre merci
beaucoup en tout cas Céline char pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 78
[Musique]
on en parlait à l'instant l'association
container sans frontières basées à
Élancourt envoyé un container de
mobilier et fourniture scolaire au
Sénégal pour en parler avec nous les
deux fondateurs de l'association
Christophe Jean Moulin et El Hadji Dramé
qu'est-ce qu'il y a motivé votre
décision d'envoyer un container de
fournitures scolaires et de mobilier
scolaire au Sénégal
tu peux commencer oui à tout avant tout
d'abord et je remercie
de nous avoir invité sur plateau et
remercier aussi mon collègue Christophe
et ce qui nous a motivé c'est
l'éducation quand on parle de
l'éducation on parle du combat quand on
parle du combat on parle du savoir et si
on perd le savoir donc on perd tout la
raison pour laquelle
c'est l'éducation que nous a posé à
faire ce projet c'est à dire à engager
la jeunesse de la France qui tend la
main vers la jeunesse de l'Afrique
que ça soit au niveau culturel
socioculturel ou ça soit organique
organisationnel tout de suite tout ce
qui est en échange avec
dans le cadre de l'échange entre les
élèves c'est ça il y a eu des élèves du
collège Gustave Courbet à Trappes qui
ont participé à ce projet exactement
depuis un 2018 les élèves Gustavo
kouroubey participent à ses projets donc
c'est ça qui nous a poussé à
continuer le projet donc à la base en
fait moi je suis arrivé un petit peu
plus tard parce que il a dit en fait à
une association
on peut les on peut les citer les
ressortissants basés sur trappes et
cette association a collaboré avec un
club solidarité qui a été créé dans mon
collège en pas par mois par un collègue
de physique-chimie qui s'appelait
monsieur Red et un CPE qui s'appelait
monsieur Lemoine qui ont été parce que
c'était pas de région parisienne mais
ils ont en 2018 ils ont lancé l'idée
d'une classe d'un club Solidar et ils
sont rentrés rapidement en contact avec
l'association des ressortis en Yaris
dont tu es un des fondateurs maintenant
tu as deux associations et donc moi je
suis arrivé en 2020 en 2020 il y avait
un projet c'était faire partir des un
groupe de ce groupe d'élèves le faire
partir au Sénégal voilà donc un projet
qui a été monté puis en 2020
malheureusement voilà ça donc au mois de
septembre le moralité dans les
chaussettes et moi je suis arrivé je
suis avec ce club existait et moi je
depuis je suis petit j'ai fait un rêve
c'est à dire
j'accepte pas que dans le monde il y a
autant de pauvreté voilà c'est parti de
ça et puis je me suis dit tiens je peux
peut-être faire quelque chose donc en
2020 le hasard a fait que je rencontre
quelqu'un alors pas il a dit une autre
personne qui cherchait du matériel
scolaire pour envoyer dans son village
au Sénégal et ça fait partie de là donc
j'ai proposé le projet aux élèves côté
tout de suite adhéré et en fait les
élèves se sont mobilisés pour nous aussi
pour pour trouver du matériel donc moi
j'ai été voir le
secrétariat du collège quand vous voyez
un mail aux établissements des Yvelines
et en fait on avait un problème c'est
que c'est pas un code nerf qu'on aurait
pu envoyer c'est deux ou trois pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur le collège
Georges Clémenceau alors je sais plus
c'est Mantes-la-Jolie il m'appelle
il me disent on a du matériel à nous
donner bon je pensais que c'était
peut-être 50 table 50 chaises en fait
c'était tout l'établissement très salle
de classe il y avait plus de place dans
le dans la cour donc quand on est arrivé
avec nos camionnettes qu'on a loué
souvent on les loue souvent soit à
Leclerc Bois-d'Arcy soit à Trappes à
France car
je suis arrivé avec cette camionnette
waouh bon on en a chargé le maximum
parce que n'avait pas assez de place
d'autant plus que on n'avait pas de lieu
de stockage aussi ma salle de classe le
collège et c'était compliqué mais je
reviendrai parce qu'on a eu après on a
réussi à trouver grâce aux collectivités
locales
[Musique]
établissement donc y compris nos
collèges le 3 lycées et les écoles
élémentaires alors qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
ressenti sur
place
de boudiri même le Président j'ai été
rencontré
c'est lui on en a discuté il a vraiment
témoigné et la population aussi a
témoigné le fait que les Trappistes les
enfants de Yvelines noires collecte du
matériel les entreprises même les
établissements envahi du Sénégal équipé
26 établissements c'est énorme donc
vraiment ça leur a beaucoup soulagé au
niveau de de l'éducation et au niveau
aussi
des financements donc voilà ça
rôle de positif et donc dimanche
prochain vous organisez une journée de
solidarité pour récolter des fonds pour
pouvoir
dans nos sources de financement parce
que on sait très bien que sans argent on
peut rien faire c'est le nerf de la
guerre dans toute dans toute action
en fait avec les élèves on organise une
journée de solidarité donc de
quel sera le programme
alors il y a beaucoup de plats africains
notamment des pastels du tiède etc même
les il y a des mamans aussi qui nous ont
fait des gâteaux des gâteaux de
pâtisserie orientales voilà il y a donc
les gens ils peuvent venir le bissap
aussi
que la boisson sénégalaise par
excellence donc ils peuvent les gens
peuvent venir boire manger quelque chose
et surtout en fait on communique autour
de ça découvrir nos actions découvrir
nos associations alors il y a une
ribambelle de d'élèves une armée pour
ainsi dire qui qui fait du porte-à-porte
là qui démarche qui pose des affiches
ici et là sur les abributs et tout ça
de financer les autres actions
de collecter de collecter de l'argent
parce que on a des frais notamment nos
frais c'est trouver les milliers d'euros
qu'il faut pour pour envoyer des
conteneurs mais on a trouvé quand même
des
d'autres sources de financement pour
vous donner des des
idées c'est que par exemple ici que je
salue
qui a un établissement public alors je
sais pas trop j'ai pas trop j'ai pas
trop spécialiste mais voilà
créé par le département des Yvelines
sous l'impulsion il faut bien le dire de
Pierre bélier qui a vraiment une fibre
qui a vraiment une fibre africaine on
peut dire et qui lutte vraiment quand la
pauvreté qui fait vraiment des choses
mais surtout de pas simplement vous
savez moi je sors d'un je sors d'un
voyage là c'était mon premier voyage
officiel durant j'ai sacrifié je suis
enseignant à Trappes qui sacrifié une
grosse partie mais c'est pas sacrifice
pour moi j'étais heureux d'aller là-bas
c'est mon premier voyage officiel j'ai
vu j'ai vu j'ai vu que le Sénégal en
fait il manquait tout mais quand on est
d'un pays africain moi je refuse de
c'est pas c'est pas des mendiants ils
ont une fierté ils ont une énergie nous
que ça soit ici ou que ça soit mon
association on a envie d'accompagner
c'est à dire que moi j'ai cette féroce
volonté que dans 30 ans si tout le monde
s'y met ben dans 30 ans peut-être les
gamins du Sénégal je sais pas s'ils
auront les mêmes moyens mais en tout cas
ils seront beaucoup moins défavorisés
parce que comme le disait mon mon
collègue il a dit en fait là on est dans
un combat le combat pour l'éducation si
on gagne pas le combat pour l'éducation
au niveau mondiale j'entends
la suite c'est l'obscurantisme si on le
gagne si on le gagne pas c'est
l'oscurantisme donc voilà
et l'a dit Dramé d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors si vous voulez faire un
don à l'association container sans
frontières vous pouvez vous rendre sur
le site internet qui s'affiche sur votre
écran votre écran sinon rendez-vous le
dimanche 18 juin pour leur journée de
solidarité à la salle Pablo Picasso de
trappe de midi à 19h30 le campus
départemental de formation Paul Cézanne
à Mantes-la-Jolie organisé ses premières
portes ouvertes le week-end dernier sur
place les référents des différentes
formations étaient présents pour
informer le public ouvert depuis octobre
2022 c'était l'occasion pour nous de
dresser un premier bilan de ce nouveau
campus 8 mois après le reportage de
Nicolas salé
journée découverte au campus de
formation Paul Cézanne au programme
visite des lieux et rencontre avec les
formateurs ce nouvel établissement
propose de multiples formations en
s'adressant en priorité aux jeunes
décrocheurs et aux demandeurs d'emploi
aujourd'hui 14 structures sont installés
donc à la fois de la formation
qualifiante et aussi de la formation
diplômante donc vous avez aussi bien un
service à la personne que de
l'informatique que du BTP et aussi tout
ce qui tourne autour de l'animation
l'objectif formé des jeunes de tous
horizons en seulement quelques semaines
en reprenant les bases je leur montre
comment comment fixer un lavabo comment
comment brancher une prise comment
comment carreler comment faire de la
peinture vraiment les bébés du métier
quoi alors là on a des compétences qui
sont des compétences techniques et à la
couleur à la technique en coiffure la
permanente à des choses très techniques
et qui se font en salon et puis aussi
des compétences pratiques qui sont liées
à la coupe qui sont liées au barberies
ce format apprentissage séduit de plus
en plus alors que de nombreux jeunes
peinent à s'intégrer dans un parcours
scolaire classique il y a
un certain rejet du système éducatif tel
qu'il existe traditionnellement donc ils
veulent des choses qui soient le moins
théorique possible le plus court
possible et donc surtout il soit certain
parce qu'ils ont trop vu le système
d'impasse que ça débouche sur un emploi
l'initiative plaît et donne de l'espoir
à de nombreux habitants du quartier ça
permet de sortir les jeunes dans leurs
difficultés de les former et de le
mettre dans un système pour leur avenir
futur depuis son ouverture à la rentrée
2022 le campus a déjà permis la
formation de plus de 750 jeunes
la 54e édition du Salon International de
l'Aéronautique et de l'Espace au Bourget
se déroulera du 19 au 25 juin prochain
tous les acteurs mondiaux de
l'aéronautique et du spatial seront
réunis pendant une semaine et les
Yvelines ne seront encore une fois très
bien représentés pour en parler avec
nous Nicolas dandry bonsoir bonsoir
alors première question tout d'abord
Nicolas un mot sur ce salon est-ce que
vous pouvez nous présenter en quelques
mots déjà c'est le grand retour de cet
événement puisque la dernière édition
s'est tenue en 2019 les éditions
suivantes ont été annulées à cause du
covid le Salon International de
l'Aéronautique et de l'Espace se déroule
sur une semaine vous l'avez dit 4 jours
pour les professionnels de
l'aéronautique et du spatial et nous y
serons Mathilde mardi et mercredi
prochain nous sommes pas spécialistes du
spatial mais nous y serons pour un
numéro spécial du skyco le magazine
économique du territoire puisque 50 ans
en Yvelines sera aussi bien représentée
c'est l'occasion en fait pour les
acteurs de l'aéronautique de faire du
business de découvrir les dernières
technologies innovation du secteur puis
les trois derniers jours sont réservés
au grand public ils pourront découvrir
des avions au sol ou dans les airs des
démonstrations notamment de la
Patrouille de France le grand public la
cible aussi des industriels et des
entreprises du secteur qui aide encore
et toujours le répète pas assez bien à
trouver des nouveaux collaborateurs et
ce sera l'objet de l'avion des métiers
il y aura vraiment un avion au sol où on
pourra découvrir les métiers beaucoup
beaucoup de nombreuses offres d'emploi
alors vous en avez un petit peu parlé
Nicolas les Yvelines seront bien
représentés et bien oui les Yvelines
terre d'aéronautique et d'aérospatiale
Mathis d'écouter c'est le deuxième
département en France en termes
d'effectif avec près de 20 000 employés
dans le secteur dans eu 308 entreprises
sur le territoire il y a des grands
groupes comme Ariane groupe aux Mureaux
et Airbus des fins de sunspace ou encore
Thalès à Elancourt puis des startups
notamment du new space notamment à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines comme
astrolabe et constellation
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines aura d'ailleurs son stand de
lors de un événement je vous l'ai dit
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ou qui
regroupe de nombreuses entreprises juste
du secteur et alors il y a un thème
cette année Nicolas alors effectivement
Mathilde vous le savez c'est dans l'air
du temps à le thème de cette édition
c'est la décarbonation de l'aviation ou
comment réduire l'empreinte carbone du
secteur de l'aéronautique et à ce propos
nous sommes rendus en début de semaine
sur le site d'un autre équipementier
aéronautique présent dans les Yvelines
il s'agit de safran landing systems à
Vélizy-Villacoublay leur spécialité les
trains d'atterrissage et nous avons
rencontré Patrick joyeuse directeur
technique et air était de safran landing
systems sur le site de Vélizy de safran
c'est les trains d'atterrissage qui
occupent les collaborateurs de safran
ici et pour en parler nous sommes avec
Patrick Joyez bonjour bonjour directeur
technique et arrêter de safran à landing
system alors tout d'abord déjà c'est
quoi un travail
systems nous offrons des systèmes
d'atterrissage complet donc on parle de
train d'atterrissage comme on voit
derrière moi
donc les structures principales qui
supportent l'avion lors de la phase de
d'atterrissage qui amortisse l'énergie
au sol et puis qui supporte l'avion
pendant toute la phase de roulage au sol
et lors du décollage mais c'est pas
seulement le train d'atterrissage c'est
aussi les roues et les freins et tout le
système de freinage et ce qui permet
également de replier et détendre le
les trains d'atterrissage dans les
phases après le décollage et avant
l'atterrissage alors en quoi aujourd'hui
le système d'atterrissage est-il
polluant
alors le système d'atterrissage n'est
pas polluant en tant que tel c'est une
grosse structure il se trouve que c'est
l'équipement qui qui est le plus lourd
au niveau de la masse à vide de l'avion
donc un système d'atterrissage complet
ça représente entre 5 et 6% de la masse
à vide de l'avion et donc il est très
utile et indispensable lors des phases
de déplacement au sol de l'avion et lors
de évidemment de l'atterrissage mais
pendant toute la phase de vol et de
croisière finalement on transporte un
bagage inutile et ce bagage contribue à
la consommation carburant de la viande
donc on fait énormément d'activités pour
alléger notre ind d'atterrissage et les
rendre plus
eco friendly si je puis dire alors l'un
des moyens justement vous parlez de
matériaux qui sont qui sont pesants
c'est de changer de matériaux peut-être
de les rendre un peu plus légers ou même
carrément de changer de passer de
l'acier à autre chose en fait absolument
il y a plusieurs défis qui qui ont lieu
en ce moment d'une part les architecture
des avions va évoluer dans le futur pour
des avions plus allégés donc avec des
ailes plus fines etc donc tout le
système d'accrochage du train sur
l'avion va être repensé et les trains
d'atterrissage en tant que tel vont voir
apparaître des nouveaux matériaux des
composites de deuxième génération pour
véritablement alléger ces structure et
faire en sorte que le bagage qu'on
transporte pendant la croisière et le et
le plus faible possible
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres moyens aussi
de rendre peut-être un peu plus
décarbonée l'avion à travers les trains
d'atterrissage oui alors au niveau des
systèmes de freinage on a commencé il y
a bien longtemps déjà avec les freins
carbone qui prennent une part
grandissante du marché ça fera le
système de fournit que des freins
carbone sur ces avions ça permet une
très grande économie de masse et dans
les procédés de fabrication du carbone
égal également nous innovons pour
réduire la consigne et de gaz utiliser
pour pour fabriquer ces matériaux une
deuxième une deuxième avancée c'est
l'électrification de nos systèmes
électrifié les systèmes permet d'alléger
la masse des systèmes hydrauliques de
l'avion et donc c'est un véritable
contributeur en plus d'améliorer la
disponibilité opérationnelle des
produits une question aussi parce que la
France c'est un grand groupe
faire un avion sur les moteurs
travailler à la fois sur le moteur
travailler sur les trains d'atterrissage
il y a beaucoup d'éléments sur lesquels
on peut avoir un pouvoir justement pour
aller vers un avion plus vert comment
vous travaillez tous ensemble les
différentes filiales ça fera landing
system ça prend aircraft engine
s'affrontait alors concevoir les
technologies de demain c'est un
véritable sport d'équipe donc on a ici
sur le site de Vélizy plus de 600
ingénieurs et on travaille tous ensemble
à développer ces nouvelles technologies
et d'ailleurs nous recrutons toujours
pour développer les nouveaux procédés
qui seront plus respectueux de
l'environnement et toute cette
technologie que vous avez vu aujourd'hui
donc notamment nous avons l'avion des
métiers au Bourget dans lequel nous
allons recruter des centaines
d'ingénieurs donc cette année nous
recrutons plus de 1000 postes sur safran
landing systems donc on a un véritable
de challenge collectif à réussir la
décarbonation de l'aviation voilà vous
recrutiez quel type de profil ingénieur
des ingénieurs mais pas seulement
également des professions achats
matériaux et procédés
une grande variété de métiers
et nécessaire à la réussite de nos
projets et sur le lien que vous avez
avec les autres entités de safran
peut-être est-ce que vous travaillez
aussi ensemble oui alors nous avons
notamment une technologie que nous que
nous préparons pour la future génération
de plateformes qui est le taxiage
électrique emblématique donc pour
pouvoir déplacer les les avions au sol
sans l'usage des moteurs principaux et
nous dans cette ce projet de recherche
nous travaillons main dans la main avec
les autres filiales de safran comme
safran electrical and power ventilation
system transmission system pour
concevoir ces produits qui mettent en
jeu l'ensemble des équipements de
l'avion et j'ai lu dans la presse qu'on
pourrait même aller jusqu'à
l'autonomie c'est à dire qu'il y aurait
le pilote toujours à bord bien
évidemment mais que le taxiège pour
faciliter disons les choses pourraient
se faire de manière autonome comme on a
déjà la technologie dans l'automobile
oui c'est un grand c'est une grande
avance
de l'aviation c'est de rendre les
opérations les plus simples et
optimisées possible donc l'automation
permet justement de d'alléger la charge
des pilotes et d'améliorer les
consommations carburant l'empreinte
environnementale donc c'est vraiment un
grand enjeu de l'aviation de demain et
c'est tous les travaux qui se déroulent
ici sur le site de Vélizy également
Vélizy et puis avec nos collaborateurs
dans le monde entier évidemment et avec
l'aide des avionneurs nous ne
travaillons pas tout seul merci beaucoup
Patrick joyeuse merci avec plaisir
directeur technique et arrêter de safran
landing system
et merci également à William Morel et
Julien Leroy au moyen technique que pour
la réalisation de ce reportage allez
c'est l'heure à présent de notre coup de
coeur cinéma d'un professionnel du
septième art cette semaine c'est le
réalisateur yvelinois Benjamin palier
qui nous parle du film ni vu ni connu
c'est un film français sorti en 1958
avec comme acteur Louis de Funès
regardez
[Musique]
cette semaine je vais vous parler du
film ni vu ni connu qui a été réalisé
par Yves Robert en 1958 avec comme
acteur principal Louis de Funès
moustache et Noël à dents ce film est
l'adaptation du roman l'affaire blaireau
qui a été écrit par Alphonse Halet en
1899 l'histoire se déroule dans un petit
village et raconte la rivalité entre
blaireau qui est un braconnier et par
jus qui est un garde champêtre du
village une erreur judiciaire se
ressemble de cette histoire blaireau
devin vite la principale occupation des
habitants et de la police de la
charmante ville de montpayard dont le
maire prenait à cause de lui des allures
dictatoriales Blairon en arrivait même à
gagner les faveurs de la femme du
Chatelard et de sa fille ce film est un
gros succès en salle puisqu'il a cumulé
presque 2 millions d'entrées au
box-office et
la prestation de Louis de Funès a été
soulignée par plusieurs journaux de
l'époque personnellement j'aime beaucoup
ce film car c'est l'un des premiers
grands rôles de Louis de Funès au cinéma
et en plus ce film a été presque
entièrement tourné en décor naturel
notamment la scène du concours de pêche
qui a été tourné sur le canal de
Bourgogne donc voilà je vous conseille
vraiment d'aller voir ce film car c'est
très drôle et puis vous passerez un très
bon moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des concerts des animations et des jeux
en plein air c'est la recette magique de
la Garden Party festival au domaine de
Madame Elisabeth à Versailles la
prochaine c'est ce samedi 17 juin pour
en parler avec nous Julien bloutin le
sous-directeur adjoint au pôle gestion
et valorisation du patrimoine pour le
département Julien Broutin c'est devenu
un peu un rendez-vous familial cette
garden party oui et déjà la troisième
édition
nous c'est notre axe notre public c'est
la famille
dans la sous une thématique Flower Power
donc imaginez par Laura aussi qui
travaille au sein du département une
sorte de petit Coachella que vous pouvez
retrouver aux États-Unis mais vraiment
recentrer sur la famille sur la gratuité
très importante c'était la commande de
du président Bédié que l'entrée soit
gratuite et des activités gratuites euh
mené par par nos agents nos bénévoles au
sein de la sous-direction et alors tout
au long de l'après-midi il va y avoir
des groupes de musique qui vont se
succéder est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
parler lesquels se sont oui donc on se
conserve au total de midi à 23h30 donc
on va pas chômer on a à peu près tous
les styles on a ACMA qui va finir donc
plus DJ on a du rock luluvin trap qui va
être le feu un peu plus un côté un peu
plus jazz avec caravane jazz quinté
corallien qui nous vient de Belgique qui
s'est fait beaucoup connaître sur
Instagram à l'instar de Albert Taouil
aussi qui sera présent pour cette
édition donc vous avez des noms un peu
connus internationaux et des groupes un
peu plus locaux
[Musique]
c'est un bon exemple qui nous vient des
Yvelines alors en parallèle vous
prévoyez aussi des animations et des
jeux en plein air vous nous en parler un
petit peu en début d'émission donc une
partie
j'ai en plein air
accessible à tous juste à nous laisser
votre carte d'identité et vous pouvez
aller jouer au badminton au volley au
criquet enfin voilà on a un panel de
jeux pour les familles et on a aussi des
cours de Zumba
sur inscription sur place dans le jardin
de l'Orangerie donc il fait partie
intégrante du domaine toute l'après-midi
est-ce que ça vous tente elle a dit
Dramé Christophe
cette action et je trouve ça absolument
bien parce que en plus
ça renforce l'idée que dans les Yvelines
il fait bon vivre il y a vraiment de
aussi un président du département qui
actif comme fibre sociale il faut le
dire et je trouve ça bien que de mettre
ça en place c'est c'est gratuit c'est
pour tout le monde et en fait je vais
vous dire le mal du monde moi j'ai loin
en tant qu'enseignant c'est le lien
social et il faut absolument créer du
lien social et ça je pense que ça y
contribue voilà alors l'objectif de cet
événement aussi Julien Boutin c'est de
faire connaître ce domaine de Madame
Élisabeth vous connaissiez le domaine ou
pas du tout justement grâce à mon
association il y a eu une assemblée
générale de l'icycine on nous a invité
début juin et moi je savais qui avait un
parc comme ça j'imaginais que sur toute
Versailles voilà c'est je voyais pas je
savais pas qu'il y avait derrière des
bâtiments parce que on y passe en
voiture qui avait un lieu aussi enfin
moi j'ai été séduit vraiment c'est c'est
grand c'est un petit Versailles mais bon
par rapport au taux de si prestigieux
mais c'est pour pour faire des
événements c'est absolument enfin c'est
génial c'est plus intimiste et plus
familial on est sur un parc de 8
hectares
parce que ce jour-là on a rencontré
beaucoup d'associations mais des
associations différentes il y a des
associations sénégalais il y a des
associations qui viennent de Cameroun
Togo des choses comme ça tout cela en
fait il y a un temps qui est dédié en
échange entre des associations entre les
autoroutes on pourra découvrir d'autres
pays les cultures des choses comme ça
vraiment c'est convivial en fait ça
mieux social voilà où on mélange
événement public événement privé pour un
peu de recettes malgré tout pour faire
vivre le site et surtout un parc public
ouvert toute l'année et
alors c'est hors de ce domaine en
quelques mots donc le domaine de Mamie
isabeth donc qui était madame Isabelle
la maîtresse
c'était la petite sœur de Louis XVI
d'accord petite sœur de Louis XVI qui
était pour elle son frère a été enfin
c'était son frère elle est vraiment une
une forte un fort lien entre c'est
pourquoi lors de la fuite à Varenne elle
a suivi son frère et donc ils se sont
fait attraper bien entendu prison du
Temple dans Paris qui n'existe plus et
deux ans après Louis XVI le tribunal
République la condamnamor et donc c'est
la dernière famille à passer sous la
guillotine à 30 ans mais d'après nos
écrits ce qu'on a fait des recherches
malgré tout on l'a surnommé quand même
la bonne dame de Montreuil puisque avant
le domaine Isabelle était situé sur le
village de Montreuil qui n'était pas
encore rattaché à Versailles et cette
dame donc cette grande dame venait tous
les jours elle n'a pas le droit d'y
dormir puisqu'elle n'est pas la majorité
et donc elle venait prodiguer des soins
au villageois et également donner la
nourriture donc tous les écrits qu'on a
retrouvés vous écrivez vraiment une
belle personne donc ça court rapprochée
et le seul homme qui pouvait donc venir
avec elle était son médecin
pour l'événement
donc c'est un événement gratuit mais sur
inscription pour le moment on a plus de
6000 inscrits et donc c'est plus par
rapport au précédentes
donc on est on est on a fait en
conséquence donc pour l'instant on a
commencé le matin ce matin et donc on
sera prêt pour samedi accueillir tous
les visiteurs et l'inscription il faut
faire comment faut s'inscrire sur un
site oui oui sur Internet vous avez le
lien avec une le site s'affiche sur
votre écran
jusqu'à le jour même on vous acceptera
même si vous venez
merci beaucoup Julien Boutin d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en plateau du
coup si vous êtes intéressé la Garden
Party festival c'est ce samedi 17 juin
au domaine de Madame Elisabeth à
Versailles rendez-vous de midi à 23h30
et en clôture cette émission par un
reportage tout du moins insolite la
France compte près de 35000 communes
pour un peu plus de 6000 code postaux de
fait plusieurs villes se partagent donc
leur code postal et certaines ont décidé
d'en jouer dans les Yvelines châteaux
forts et Toussus-le-Noble ce sont
affrontés avec le sourire dans des
Olympiades alors qui a gagné qui a gagné
la réponse avec Mélanie pocket et Thomas
Fletcher
[Musique]
en rouge château fort en bleu tout sur
le noble un objectif 78 117 qui n'est
autre que le code postal que ce partage
à château fort est touché le noble
qui en est digne pour se départager les
deux communes se sont affrontés autour
des Princes sportives une chose est sûre
les équipes mères en tête étaient
motivés à la façon de voir les choses et
on va réfléchir on dira ça à la fin sur
les a laissé gagner parce que il nous
accueillait ou si parce qu'ils étaient
meilleurs
à la suite de 7 ou 8 jeux d'équipe et
que le meilleur gagne
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous allons nous battre pour
le code postal Patrice révélation
les épreuves sont lancées
[Applaudissements]
se jouent par catégorie d'âge ils sont
une soixantaine à avoir souhaité en
découdre à croire en leur équipe et en
leur village
font des choses ensemble dans le château
fort il y a beaucoup d'activités
[Musique]
là on est à tous eu donc c'est normal
qu'il y a plein de habitants qui vont
venir pour soutenir l'équipe quoi parce
que nous on a des avions ils n'en n'ont
pas
nous on vole on glisse on est uni bon
après je ne connais pas mais moi je
pense qu'il n'y a aucun doute sur le
fait qu'on gagne tire à la corde cours
105 glisse ski voici quelques-unes des
épreuves une ambiance bon enfant avec un
but solidaire une tombola permet de
récolter des fonds pour des chiens
guides d'aveugles mon chien que vous
voyez ici est le millième chien qui a
été formé et confié par l'association à
des malvoyants je dis toujours il m'a
rajeuni de 10 ans c'est à dire que
là il y a le côté
gain d'autonomie gain enfin que tout le
monde peut imaginer un chien guide ça
vous guide comme son nom l'indique il y
a aussi le côté le dans le regard des
autres
vous n'êtes pas avec une canne blanche
et les gens oublient que vous êtes
malvoyants ou aveugle après trois heures
d'épreuve les Bleus s'inclinent château
fort remporte cette première édition de
jeu intervillage la revanche ce sera
l'an prochain dans la ville gagnante
et bien bravo à château fort pour cette
victoire c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission mais avant de se quitter je
vous propose de jeter un dernier coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
matin le soleil sera présent dans tout
le département côté température ça
montre à vite il fera 20 degrés à
Rambouillet et Houdan et 21 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles dans
l'après-midi le soleil sera toujours en
place et les températures seront
toujours aussi chaudes compter en
moyenne 28 à 29 degrés et c'est la fin
de cette émission merci pour votre
fidélité je vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]